let's go to alexander the texan next
alexander the texan you're on the air
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
okay uh
i was just wondering so
there seems to be a subset of leftists
in america that i would call america bad
leftist okay what do you think what do
you think drives their uh
i would call it propagandistic
uh coverage of like this russia ukraine
situation
i think you'd really have to ask them i
mean i think if your starting point is
the us is uniquely bad
then that's your hammer right and so
everything will look like a nail russia
ukraine is an opportunity to say the u.s
is bad
um uh venezuela is an opportunity to say
the u.s is bad cuba is an opportunity
you know if if you're committed to the
hammer everything looks like a nail and
i think i think it's that for some
specific people
we've later found out about financial
ties to some authoritarian regimes and
so for some people there may be a
financial aspect to it but i don't think
there's anything
particularly hidden you know i mean i
think it's just a lot for a lot of
people it's like hey look at this
terrible thing china's doing yeah but
the us also does bad things
right yeah and i criticize those but
we're talking about china right now i
think you get the point right and so i
think i think it's quite it's quite that
simple that's all it is
okay yeah well that's really all that i
wanted i'll let you move on to the next
caller i value your opinion david and
thank you for taking my call all right
and are you you're are you bunkering
hunkering down for the upcoming winter
storm there in texas uh yes i am and i'm
hoping that we have a little bit better
luck this year and a little more
competence on the part of uh yeah my
particular municipality that's what i'm
holding and this aid as a whole that's
what i'm hoping for all right uh stay
safe down there alexander thank you
thank you very much david all right
alexander the texan checking in
if you or someone you know is into
science astronomy space this is for you
our sponsor under lucky stars creates
beautiful personalized star maps
showing the unique position of the stars
in the sky
at the place and time chosen by you
under lucky stars is a great way to
remember an important moment someone's
birthday wedding day your engagement you
give them a time and a location that you
want to commemorate they show you
exactly how the stars and constellations
looked in a spectacular super high
quality print it's a completely
personalized gift experience you can
customize it into a ton of designs you
can read on their website how all the
star maps are scientifically accurate
this is the one i got showing the time
of my birth in buenos aires argentina
the quality of the material and the
print they're fantastic i was really
impressed under lucky stars is perfect
for valentine's day and right now
they're giving my viewers 10 off when
you click the link below and enter the
code d pacman